[Music]
this cutter is able to perform a 320
km/h but this is not the best figure I'm
Filippo Perini responsible of design of
the chain to steal a Lamborghinis this
is real carbon-fiber after Jana is a
clear classic interpretation of our
first hybrid platform remember that this
car has 910 horsepower is the most
powerful a beginning ever but we decided
that this car needs a different dress
because it's clever we don't want a
performance but we want a clever
performance and the middle console where
we have is huge because we have the
battery inside
I was surprised I'm not a big fan of a
hybrid but I was really impressed
because of our hybrid it I say to you
the way is delivering the power is a
very very very elegant we will never
forget our water capability to do
supercar with extreme and beautiful
design but I think that in the side we
can start with a new range of product
this is my personal dream and this
product can be addressed with something
that is different
I don't know why down this is the most
important centers for me why not